2020 marks 400 years since the mayflower
carried some of the first european
settlers across the atlantic ocean
to north america to commemorate the
anniversary another vessel is
recreating that voyage but as roxanna
seberry reports this journey will look
and feel much different
among the yachts and freighters floating
in the harbor at plymouth england
a little ship is warming up for a big
journey
we don't know how it's it's going to go
is it is it going to make it across the
atlantic fingers crossed that
it does have a successful first voyage
success is uncertain because though the
vessel will rely on the latest
navigation technology when it sets out
to see this spring
you get all sorts of cameras so here
here here
it won't carry a crew or a captain
it has no people in it there's no people
space
instead robotics expert brett favre says
artificial intelligence designed by ibm
will guide it so it looks at its own
cameras like eyes it looks at the radar
it looks at all sorts of other sensors
and then it charts its own course and it
can deal with unique situations without
any human input
there is a hazard to navigation
situations like other ships it could
encounter along the way
course change required but to recognize
them
humans like software engineer ali
thompson are trading it with more than a
million
images so we can see here that we're
able to track other vessels
what we're doing is simulating what
she's uh what she's seeing
that's what you don't want the ship to
run into absolutely yeah
programmers are also setting the ship's
destination
plymouth massachusetts retracing the
voyage made by the mayflower
400 years ago this month it took that
wooden merchant ship
66 days to transport dozens of pilgrims
across the atlantic
in the 1950s a replica sailed from
england to massachusetts
wore its dock today but faneuf who grew
up near plymouth massachusetts
wanted to mark the mayflower's famous
past by looking ahead
instead i thought well we should build a
ship
that speaks to the next 400 years what
the marine enterprise will look like
then as opposed to
what it looked like 400 years ago an
international team turned his vision
into this solar and wind-powered
mayflower autonomous ship
its mission software developer rosie
licorice says is to learn more about our
oceans
by gathering data on plastic pollution
warming waters
and their effects on marine life it's
very expensive at the moment for
scientists to actually go out on these
research missions so having autonomous
vessels like the mayflower autonomous
ship is
is really an important step and kind of
actually enabling us to go out to
these dangerous places and learn a lot
more other boats have tested similar
technology
take for instance this car ferry that
can dock by itself
but the new mayflower is one of the
world's first fully self
navigating ships to take on the 3 000
mile
transatlantic trip what are the benefits
to not having any crew
in here nobody gets tired or hurt or
sick and
we can keep the ship very small what is
your biggest fear with this vessel
something silly breaks that we didn't
think of and it slowly crashes into
ireland
could it capsize sure that would be kind
of sad but yeah that i wouldn't want
that to happen
have we thought of every possible
situation if it does the team plans to
track the ship via satellite and salvage
it
but if the unmanned voyage succeeds
faneuf says it will commemorate history
while charting a new path i want people
to look back on this 400 years
from now and think about how different
this was from what other people were
doing
it's a future he says that the world is
just starting
to imagine for cbs this morning saturday
roxanna saberi plymouth england
sort of no surprise there when you look
at autonomous cars
that it would make sense that we start
moving in the direction of what's out
there on the water but the fact that
they can look at the plastic pollution
warming temperatures i think that's
great
it's fascinating to see and i mean so
many obstacles we'll see how long it
actually
takes for that journey to be completed